[Musique]
ce mercredi trois mille laurence mondon
vice président du département a
participé à la pose de la première
bordure de la route départementale 27 le
département en partenariat avec la
commune du tampon engage la révision de
la route de bras de pontho les entre
saint-pierre et le tampon il est
important pour le département de
soutenir ce projet puisque nous
travaillons en collaboration avec la
commune du tampon au travers du pacte
territorial de solidarité et il était
important pour nos effectivement d'avoir
ce chantier réalisé puisque la la
sécurité des riverains c'est la plus
importante d'autant plus que sur cette
route départementale qu il ya plus de
1800 véhicules qui circulent par jour
donc la sécurité est primordiale ses
épouses les travaux permettront
l'installation d'arrêt de bus aménagé
avec des bordures adapté et la
rénovation entière de la chaussée alors
surtout les travaux de sécurisation
donc ça veut dire qu'en fait d'éviter un
confort supplémentaire aux usagers parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une courte sur
cette portion là où il n'y a pas de
trottoir
les piétons sont obligés de marcher
directement sur la chaussée ou sur
l'accotement en typhon et ces travaux
vont permettre justement la création
d'un fonds tout en permettant
l'amélioration de la gestion des eaux
la mise en place un réseau plus un
budget de 780 à 7000 euros pour ce
chantier du tronçon de bras de pontho
financé à hauteur de 621 1000 euros par
le département
[Musique]